there are so many so many new candidates
to get to ladies and gentlemen it's like
every week now another week another
kindred this week everybody ready for
Marco Rubio
oh my god yeah they're all saying you
know he's fresh he's new I'll say he
looks like it could be Hillary Clinton's
pool boy this guy well you know
everybody's gotta have a stick you know
he's kind of a thing then his thing is
I'm young I'm young I'm new I'm fresh
I'm boyish yeah when Ted Cruz reads
green eggs and ham he listens he's young
now the other day he's I swear to God he
proclaimed yesterday's over [ __ ] deep
man okay
he got my vote no he's a his slogan is a
new American Century but he's against
abortion in all situations against gay
marriage against immigration reform
against legalizing pot against clean
energy development it sounds a lot like
the old century to me you know what
I am NOT a big fan of mr. Chris Christie
but at least he is talking about real
problems he was in New Hampshire this
week talking to a room full of all white
people and he said we have to cut your
Social Security benefits and raise the
retirement age I mean you got to admit
he has balls
he hasn't seen them in 30 years but he
asked but you know he chose this week as
we had tax day we all had to pay our
taxes on Wednesday I know but something
else really important happened on tax
day in the labor movement you may not
have heard about it because Hillary ate
a burrito in Iowa but on tax day
fast-food workers went on strike in 230
cities around the country yeah it's a
big deal
trying to get a $15 an hour work fee
which is the least that you need to live
on the right to form a union better they
want better employee health care plan
right now their employee health care
plan is donate the food we make of
course the fast-food chains are all
saying you know if we raise wages we're
gonna have to charge more and use
cheaper ingredients could you really do
that
have you tried the macam stir but don't
worry Congress felt the minimum wage
workers pain in this week they passed a
bold new plan to completely eliminate
the inheritance tax on the super-rich
how does this happen in a democracy how
does John Boehner look at himself in the
mirror when he is varnishing his face
I mean people working for $8 an hour and
the other people who were supposed to
represent everyone the same people who
never shut up about the deficit just
voted a twenty billion dollar hole in
the budget to go to five thousand club
kids with a trust fund but the guy who
landed on the Capitol and the gyrocopter
who thinks would you get the money out
of politics
he's the nut not in my book and you know
and yeah when you talk about this
inheritance tax which goes to like five
thousand people this is where
conservatives always say
what about family farmers well the last
time they measured this in 2013 of those
five thousand millionaires and
billionaires who pay the estate tax
farmers 2020 farmers paid it twenty four
Americans have been to the moon more
astronauts have been to the moon than
farmers who paid the inheritance tax in
2013 there there are more people in the
wu-tang clan that has made the
inheritance tax there are more old guys
in the expendable movies Jesus I tell
you the American capacity distract
ourselves from the real issues like
people starving with [ __ ] like this
week I see the I won't serve gay people
movement gathering steam first it was
just I won't give them a wedding cake in
bed it was pizza parlors this we get
this a car repair shop in Michigan guy
says no I'm not going to do it it's a
Christian auto shop so if you have a
transmission that's possessed by demons
this is the place to go
Wow there is a positive story on the
flip side of that a Jesuit priest that's
Pope Frank's order the Jesuits in San
Francisco came out as gay that's
happened before in the Catholic Church
but this is new unprecedented he has the
full blessing of his superiors this
never happened before not only are they
accepting of them they're fighting to
see who gets to be his roommate well so
it was another Fe week shall we say for
the police we saw a new wrinkle in
apprehending a suspect and you see the
cop who just [ __ ] ran down a guy did
you see that guy just jumps the curb
with his car and runs him down this was
in Arizona where to be fair it says
right on the police cars to protect and
swerve
and in Oklahoma you saw that one a 73
year old volunteer hobby sheriff thought
he was tasing a guy but accidentally
shot him he might have thought he had
the remote in his hand what you know
we've had we've had hands up don't shoot
we've had back turn don't shoot now we
have whose idea to take Gramp on a
ride-along don't you getting all worked
up so barely begun okay this is the the
fun story of the week this is really
true I'm not making this up scientists
say they have a new treatment for
erectile dysfunction it involves a drug
that gives you wood your penis is
exposed to blue light I'm just saying
things could get pretty weird at Kmart